hi this is Matt Welch for recent TV I'm
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas with the
political consultant and commentator
Dick Morris who's here talking about
national school choice week and school
reform writ large and no you're in a
hurry basically want to ask you one
question it feels like we're at kind of
an irresistible force movement or just
kind of movement with school choice
right now and yet there is this
immovable object assess for us quickly
where we are in that struggle between
the two and is this is this object which
actually a move well we've tried
everything else we've tried to raise
spending we've tried to strengthen
curriculums we've tried to require
better teacher preparation we tested
students nothing has worked totally flat
for 20 years so Americans are getting
the point and parents are insisting as a
matter of their personal rights their
personal civil liberties to be able to
choose where their child goes to school
that's a fundamental moral right and
that in movable object of the teachers
union ain't so immovable or is there are
there examples of that starting to break
down and crumble around us where do you
see it playing out in the next couple
years the entire state of Indiana is
converting to school choice the whole
state so is Ohio so is Wisconsin at
least in the Milwaukee area from
Wisconsin the Pittsburgh area for
Pennsylvania the Memphis area for
Tennessee Denver Colorado whole state of
Arizona those are all now one hundred
percent pro-choice school choice
jurisdictions and it's spreading like
crazy across the country and is there a
is there a politics that is not being
taken advantage of on the national level
since you're a political consultant are
people leaving this off the table on the
national scene or people starting to
embrace this or getting involved in it
well it's manifesting itself more as a
state and gubernatorial issue but the
fundamental backing for the Liberal
Democratic Party has always been the
votes of women because it's always been
based
issues of social conservatism and choice
on abortion but now the school choice
movement is superseding that and moving
people toward away from a strict Liberal
Democratic orthodoxy that's great thank
you very much dick morris for recent TV
i'm at welch